was für menschen machen so etwas das
auto als waffe nutzen worauf lässt so
etwas schließen
ja man kann sicherlich etwas darüber
sagen warum menschen so etwas tun wenn
man sich die daten anderer fälle
anschaut über diesen konkreten fall kann
oder will ich zu dem zeitpunkt noch
nicht sein und kann es auch nicht weil
das einfach noch zu früh ist und gerade
in diesen lagen ändern sich auch die
informationen die man für gesichert hält
permanent ich erinnere nur an den
terroranschlag in wien wo es hieß sechs
vielleicht sogar sieben täter sind
unterwegs und später hat sich
herausgestellt dass war doch ein täter
aber durch die schüsse kann man ganz
manchmal gar nicht klar sagen wie die
lage eigentlich aussieht ja warum tun
menschen so etwas
ich glaube man kann über die phänomene
und ich würde zwischen aragon
terrorismus keine strikte linie mehr
ziehen denn diese strikte linie gibt es
eigentlich nicht mehr oder sie ist
eigentlich nicht mehr zeitgemäß wenn sie
sich die ganzen letzten jahre oder die
ganzen letzten taten anschauen die wir
gesehen haben dann muss man sagen dass
die tatmittel wir haben terroranschläge
gesehen die mit fahrzeugen verübt wurden
und wir haben amok taten gesehen die mit
lkws oder mit mit fahrzeugen verübt
wurden man muss sagen dass die tatmittel
die ähnlichkeit zwischen am morgen
terrors immer größer auch die profile
der täter werden immer ähnlicher und die
klassische abgrenzung die man früher mal
getroffen hat amok ist persönlich
terrorist politisch gilt nicht mehr ich
will an taten wie die von hanau erinnern
da mischen sich vollkommen klar
rassistische motive mit persönlichen
motiven deswegen sage ich die motivation
wenn es persönliche gründe hat dann
sprechen wir von amok und sagen es war
eine amokfahrt und wenn jemand dabei
allahu akhbar ruft dann sprechen wir von
terrorismus meine these ist dass sowohl
die tatmittel als auch die profile als
auch die motive zunehmend ähnlicher sind
so dass man kaum noch eine klare grenze
zwischen den taten ziehen kann was genau
hier zugrunde liegt das ist noch zu früh
das zu sagen aber wenn ich mir all die
letzten jahre und taten anschaue wie
findet man die ursache heraus die
ursache findet man heraus indem man nach
dem kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner
zwischen den taten schaut
manche täter haben sich auf gar keine
ideologie bezogen dann nennen wir es
amok manche haben sich auf eine rechte
recht terrorismus von rechts und manche
haben sich auf islamistische radikale
ideologie
bezogen dann nennen wir es
islamistischen terrorismus aber die
gemeinsamkeit ist es sind männer
terrorismus und amok sind männliche
phänomene das kann man ziemlich klar
sagen ich mache mir nicht an die frage
zu beantworten warum es immer männer
sind aber es ist erst mal ein fakt den
mann ziemlich klar beobachten kann
was kann man noch sagen es sind meistens
junge männer hier soll der mutmaßliche
täter 51 sein zumindest war das die zahl
die ich gehört habe es sind
typischerweise eher jüngere männer und
was man ziemlich klar sagen kann sind
sie sind sie glücklich wenn man die
frage mal ganz offen stellt ist die
antwort nein sie sind frustriert und
zwar auf verschiedenen ebenen meistens
auf globaler ebene sind generell mit
ihrem leben unzufrieden man sagt
psychosoziale isoliert also keine
partnerin oftmals kein stabiler
freundeskreis es fehlt dieser halt und
ich würde jede wette eingehen dass auch
in diesem fall man noch ein ereignis
findet was zwei bis drei wochen im
zeitraum vor der tat liegt das kann eine
trennung sein
das kann ein jobverlust sein das kann
eine andere lebenskrise oder kränkung
sein
die manchmal noch eine auslöser für
diese taten ist wie geht es jetzt in
diesen sekunden in diesen minuten weiter
was ist jetzt ermittlungstaktische
entscheidend um eben das motiv des
täters herauszufinden was muss da alles
beachtet werden
ja natürlich muss erst mal vernommen
werden und auch die chance bekommen sich
zur tat zu äußern
gerade bei so emotionalen taten ist es
auch nicht selten dass täter das tun
dass sie den drang haben auch danach
etwas dazu zu sagen es gibt ja bei so
taten wie diesen keine ernste absicht
damit davonkommen zu wollen
das heißt die rede bereitschaft ist
oftmals da und die chance muss natürlich
auch gegeben werden und da muss man aber
auch den ermittlungsbehörden ein
bisschen zeit geben denn gerade bei
diesen sensiblen fällen wo auch alle
darüber berichten und alle wollen jetzt
die antwort auf die frage haben was ist
das motiv aber da muss man ein bisschen
verständnis aufbringen dass das
natürlich auch ein bisschen zeit kostet
das raus zu kriegen aber das allererste
was noch wichtiger ist ist natürlich
sicher zu gehen dass keine gefahr mehr
ausgeht das ist tatsächlich ein
einzeltäter ist und es keine keine
weitergehende gefahr gibt das scheint
jetzt ziemlich sicher zu sein zumindest
wenn man sich die aussagen der polizei
anhört scheinen sie nicht davon
auszugehen dass es weitere täter gibt
aber auch im falle von amok bin ich kein
freund von diesem begriff des entweder
entweder die tat einer gruppe oder des
einzeltäters denn taten passieren nie im
luftleeren raum die person haben ja
immer einen gewissen umkreis eine
familie eine umfeld vielleicht chat
gruppen in denen sie sich befinden das
heißt auch wenn die motive
höchstpersönlich sind gibt es immer ein
umfeld was dabei auch eine rolle spielt
und das gilt es natürlich auch zu
analysieren herauszukriegen was
möglicherweise die ursache war
und auch herauszukriegen das ist nicht
unwichtig ob die tat länger im vorfeld
geplant war oder ob es ganz impulsiv war
das tatmittel fahrzeug spricht eher
dafür dass es nicht von langer hand
geplant war
und auch der ort jemand der wie man es
oft bei terroristischen taten sieht wenn
das ziel darin besteht möglichst viele
personen in einem kurzen zeitraum mit in
den tod zu reißen dann gibt es durchaus
andere tatmittel beispielsweise
schusswaffen oder andere orte größere
menschenansammlungen die bessere ziele
besser aus sicht der täter vollkommen
klar wären das heißt hier gibt es einige
hinweise darauf dass es möglicherweise
doch typisch für amoktaten etwas ist was
sehr impulsiv aus einer vielleicht
kränkung oder einer krise herausgekommen
ist und eine sache die jetzt weniger
fachlich sondern er persönlich ist aber
nach aller erfahrung was man über
kriminelle sagen kann kann ich als
faustregel mal sagen drei krisen sind
eine zu viel
menschen können bis zu zwei lebenskrisen
ziemlich gut händeln das ist auch etwas
was mir einer meiner ausbilder damals
gesagt hat ein sehr erfahrener agent aus
den usa der sich auch viel mit mit
suiziden beschäftigt hat oder personen
die an der kante stehen und er sagt wenn
sie zwei lebenskrisen haben gibt es eine
gute chance dass sie zurückkommen bei
der dritten springen sie drei krisen
sind einer zuviel wir alle keine
rückschläge man verliert vielleicht im
leben die die partnerin die ehe man
verliert vielleicht den job oder man
verliert vielleicht einen geliebten
menschen hat einen todesfall
typischerweise haben wir aber insofern
glück dass diese lebenskrise nicht
gleichzeitig kommen sie kommen
nacheinander
wir erleben jede alles davon irgendwann
mal aber wenn alles drei gleichzeitig
kommt dann kann es gefährlich werden und
leider führt es auch manchmal dazu dass
menschen dann einen einen
unkontrollierten wutausbruch bekommen
und auf diese art sich manchmal auch ins
scheinwerferlicht
katapultieren und corona ist wenn sie so
wollen eine krise die wir alle gemeinsam
haben
ich habe keine ahnung ob es direkt etwas
damit zu tun hat
aber ich würde behaupten dass es
mindestens einen einfluss hat denn
corona ist eine so angespannte situation
bei vielen kochen die emotionen über
es ist eine lebenskrise die wir alle
gerade gemeinsam haben und wenn dann
noch zwei dazu kommen dann kann es
manchmal zu solchen taten führen ja aber
in diesem konkreten fall gilt es
abzuwarten was das motiv ist aber im
allgemeinen denke ich kann man dies zu
amoktaten oder taten doch so sagen
hoffmann wir sind journalisten ermittler
fragen ganz anders nach so einer tat so
kurz nach der tat heute wird es eine
erste vernehmung geben wie beginnt man
sowas wie fragt man dann den
mutmaßlichen täter um auf seine
motivlage zu schließen wenn er das nicht
gleich von sich aus sofort erzählt ja
manchmal muss man gerade wenn es um den
zeitraum direkt nach der tat geht dann
gibt es gar keinen gar kein vernehmung
raum es gibt sowieso kaum vernehmung
reue in deutschland das findet er im
großraumbüro stadt oder nicht so wie die
meisten leute sich das aus csi miami und
den anderen serien vorstellen gerade bei
solchen taten müssen sie meistens keine
frage stellen sondern es passiert eher
eine spontane äußerung es ist nicht
selten so dass personen schon auf der
fahrt ins polizeipräsidium ihre aussagen
machen die unter bestimmten bedingungen
auch später verwendet werden
in dem fall übrig sich die frage die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass personen von
sich aussprechen oder eine spontane
äußerung wir machen uns doch sehr groß
der fahrer hat sich bei der festnahme so
hieß es seitens der polizei heftig
gewehrt wie werten sie das sie sagten ja
eingangs wenn man so eine tat begeht
dann ist einem ja klar dass man da nicht
mehr raus kommen können sie irgendwelche
schlüsse daraus ziehen dass sich der
fahrer in diesem fall heftig gegen seine
festnahme gewehrt hat offensichtlich war
dass eine tat die im rausch der
emotionen passiert ist zumindest deutet
einiges darauf hin weil es doch das
tatmittel der ort ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher ob das das werk wochenlanger
planung war oder doch etwas was
vielleicht irgendwas plastischer zu
formulieren ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
er heute beim frühstück beim aufstehen
schon wusste was heute am abend
passieren wird manchmal ist es etwas was
innerhalb des natürlich gibt es schon
eine frustration lage die da ist aber
der wortwörtliche tropfen der das fass
zum überlaufen bringt es manchmal etwas
an diesem tag manchmal minuten vorher
passiert es gibt aber auch gleichzeitig
oft tief sitzende kränkungen die länger
andauern
der psychiater reinhard haller hat mal
über einen amokläufer mit dem er
gesprochen hatte gesagt er hat als
ursache für den für die amoktat damals
angegeben er wurde mal auf klassenfahrt
vor 10 oder 15 jahren wollte keiner mit
ihm aufs zimmer
rs wurde gewählt und erst am ende übrig
geblieben das mag aus unserer sicht fast
lächerlich klingt vor 15 jahren wurde er
mal auf irgend einer klassenfahrt nicht
gewählt aber es gibt manchmal das sind
narben auf der seele es gibt manchmal